and ponder the question
what if
time
space
reality
excitement i am the watcher
i am your guy through these vast new
realities look buddy anything sounds
impressive when you use that voice i am
the sin master i am your guide through
these vast inconsistencies
see what if roll commercials we're not
even out of the opening credits yet also
why the question mark marvel i mean if
you drop the ellipses it could be a
complete sentence but once you add those
it indicates there's more of a sentence
to come which means the punctuation
should follow the sentence this should
either be what if what if or if you want
to get really freaky and indicate the
return ellipses what if this just looks
like a question mark that accidentally
has four downstairs tittles that's right
i said tittles at humanity's darkest
hour a skinny kid from brooklyn became
captain america using your precious
little storytelling time to rehash
movies we've already seen the show isn't
called what was marvel bring on swole
carter already agent carter wouldn't you
be more comfortable in the booth that's
the moment
that created a new universe except
things must have already diverged
because in the version we've seen steve
was already in the harder better faster
stronger machine and this kernel looked
a lot more like stranix from under siege
[Music]
originally this explosion happens after
steve has been transformed why would
penny's arbitrary decision to choose
ringside seats to the buffening result
in a change in the timing of a plan that
had already been set in motion long
before a said decision was made am i
going to point out every tiny
discrepancy between this and the first
avenger only time will tell stark you go
in what are you crazy i push the buttons
and the buns got the church i grew up in
had a buttons guy he wore all sorts of
weird buttons on a suit he seemed fine
until one day he brought a piece of
wooden axe to service and started
chopping in front of the congregation
without warning while shouting about
pruning the evil branches keep an eye on
stark is all i'm saying agent carter
what are you doing this is our only
chance now is it though you still have
all the super juice and the machine
itself appears to be intact i feel like
somebody really wanted a new timeline
but didn't put the time in to make it
all line up start don't do this is that
bradley whitford was he in the original
cap movie you think you can just add
brad to your little tv show to make him
feel more important whitford is a
treasure and i'm sitting you for not
having him in the movie too and yes i
know he played the same role in a short
that was attached to the home release of
iron man 3 but do you think i watched
that i barely even watched iron man 3.
did it work and then some you won't be
needing those hills anymore she never
needed them ever also she's hawked out
here so much that that cami should be
shredded most clothes wouldn't have
stood a chance and buff carter should be
in the buff carter right now for
authenticity reasons of course women
aren't soldiers they sure as hell don't
fight on the front lines they might
break a nail colonel flynn survives this
seriously colonel flynn is such an
[ __ ] in this show they might as well
have named him colonel [ __ ] colonel
hull colonoscopy not according to
colonel flynn weapons
funny reveal but you do realize this
means that this room had at least 15 of
these giant weights and she's thrown
this many of them into this poor
defenseless wall kind of a dick move if
you ask me which you did when you
clicked on the video so this one's on
you uh it could be worse flynn could
stick you on one of those uso tours wear
a crazy costume being told to smile 10
times a day why isn't peggy doing the
morale boosting rounds like steve did in
the original timeline if anything and
not saying this is right wouldn't the
army brass see a woman as even more
morale boosting for the men on the front
line bucky
bucky i'd hope perhaps naively that
crossing into a new space-time continuum
would be enough to save us from the
whole mad about bucky subplot that
stalked us for over a decade we haven't
talked about this animation style yet
but i'm pretty much hating it it's like
rotoscoping got cell shading pregnant
after an intense three-way with some
binary code and then drove out to the
middle of the uncanny valley for the
birth then why do you try so hard to
hide it so hard more like not hard
enough this ancient mystical artifact of
immeasurable power is kept safe and
secure in a box inside a wall guarded by
one elderly bearded gentleman and can be
accessed by pushing one [ __ ] button
heck howard stark could have even
completed that mission button guy call
back this doesn't concern you you're
lucky to be in the room title of my sex
tape why did stark redesign the costume
in this very tasteful shade of god save
the queen yes carter is british but she
still works for the u.s right or is a
female captain america just that one
step too far
that was brilliant let's give it another
go is the show insinuating that captain
crunches is trying to figure out these
things for the first time in actual
enemy combat or is that just the rush
nature of trying to squeeze a whole
story into 30 minutes either way
carter's new look is amazing and it's
worth pointing out that marvel is
directly indicating that the cultural
idea of female beauty could use a little
beefing up i for one i'm loving it and
this in removal is for letting peggy be
completely union jacked also if peggy
looks in a mirror at some point and says
that is great britain's ass i'm giving
back all the sins are you seeing this
who is she talking to the action in this
episode and this scene in particular is
easier to follow and of better quality
than 90 of the action we're presented
with in the damn movies another sin off
bad guy cracks his neck calmly as an
indication that he's super tough cliche
exactly is that it why does everyone
keep underestimating how important the
tesseract is red skull went to all that
trouble to find the damn thing only to
immediately lose it by allowing it to be
transported by these clowns instead of a
battalion of tanks i trust you know what
to do with that
oh i know exactly what to do with this
well i'm glad somebody does because it's
been over a decade now and i still don't
have a clue what the damn thing does
does super soldier serum also provide
actual physical skills like jumping a
motorcycle through a fence i get the
strength and dexterity thing but
wouldn't you still need actual
proprioceptive training beyond the
inherent physical qualities but are they
just matrix that should enter your brain
as well
what is the point of this excellent
vantage point if you wait until after
the enemies breached the gates and
killed three of your comrades did your
friends here hurt you did they steal
your bratwurst from the communal fridge
now admittedly this iron giant man is
very cool but wouldn't it have been
cooler to let this be captain carter's
story feels like we're stepping on her
moment in the spotlight by allowing
steve to swoop in and be the hero in
this timeline as well well then we
better start dancing
[Music]
captain carter's dancing looks strangely
like murder oh
i miss a good whiskey then why did you
immediately ruin it by putting ice in it
i'm still that skinny kid from brooklyn
now just in a big metal suit a big metal
suit powered by an infinite power source
that's capable of destroying tanks and
basically anything in its path yeah you
got nothing brooklyn you're more than
the suit the suit is nothing without the
man inside you're my butt
hey barnes stole a jeep grand theft snog
blocking honestly i have no idea why
bucky and these other five guys are even
needed on this mission if the 60 million
dollar super soldier in the infinity
stone-powered suit of armor can't handle
it i fail to see how steven's other love
interest and his buddies are gonna make
the difference something about this
smells as fresh as three day old fish
or maybe you're just afraid of trains
this dig about bucky being afraid of
trains is very specific and only really
makes sense if peggy knows that bucky
was lost and presumed dead after he was
thrown from a train in the other
timeline which she most certainly
shouldn't look at the size of that zip
line are you telling me the best plan
you could come up with with getting on
the train was to set up a thousand foot
eye zip line stretching over a mile and
then time it perfectly base jumping
makes more sense than this and base
jumping never makes sense
thanks you almost ripped my arm off
you said the hydra stomper was
indestructible it is was his name
is steve rogers not the hydra stomper
hold your horses there peggy to be fair
they were specifically arguing about the
suit being indestructible no one is
under the impression that steve is too
soon too bad i will tell you nothing
he told me everything
implied torture tactics oh you rap
scallion come on howard we might need
someone to push a button button guy call
back
ours was funnier if this is the big
hydra hideout why does its external
defenses consist of only half a dozen
soldiers an uncoated gate release button
and zero sentries where are the damn
tanks where are the snipers why is
castle who needs a plan i have a shield
a shield is not a plan what if howard
stark was excellent at tv since the
champion of hydra has risen your super
powerful ultimate champion world
dominating being from another dimension
sure looks suspiciously like an octopus
so no plan b in the event that you were
unable to communicate with this extra
dimensional creature thus being unable
to immediately bend it to your will you
just get squished alrighty then stark
was right indestructible
steve
steve how thoughtful of evil hydra
agents to keep steve in the same room as
his super suit despite the dozens of
other rooms that are no doubt available
in this castle german efficiency man you
can't beat it now where's peggy she drew
the high card this suit could give out
at any minute and bucky thinks up is
enough specificity to allow steve to get
to peggy in the shortest amount of time
possible how the rate is spreading
how the [ __ ] did she manage to
extrapolate that one it hasn't even
filled this room yet what makes her
think it will continue to grow to
continent devouring size excuse me i'm
just gonna grab my sword of unbelievable
convenience
red green blue who paints the bottom
blue the blue man group the smurfs
eiffel 65 shall i continue don't tell me
the american playboy needs help
was that a clitoris joke because i think
there's a clitoris joke in there but i'm
having a really difficult time locating
it
did you miss me for the second time in
this outing the man has come to save the
day and rescue the female hero did no
one at marvel realize this was a dumb
ass idea which fundamentally undermines
the impact of this female captain
america's story where steve watches
the war
ended
almost 70 years ago that's a strange way
of saying who's steve rogers also
apparently everything else went exactly
the same even though you changed the
timeline guess there's no carter fly
effect who's gonna tell ashton i observe
all that transpires here but i do not
cannot will not interfere then is there
really any point to you at all
[Music]
steve rogers steve
steve steve steve steve
go get him steve his name is steve
[Music]
rogers fish are friends not food
hang on i'll be right back i'll be right
back hey vasquez
have you ever been mistaken for a man no
have you
is this nuclear no no no no this
sucker's electrical don't say it don't
you say it left come on
steam
steve
you are where you choose to be
[Music]
hi i noticed your glass was getting a
little low so i took the liberty of
bringing you another apple martini
and i couldn't help but notice you look
a lot like my next girlfriend
thanks try to listen so do you like
cuban food
that is sort of an oaky after birth
hold it hold it is this a kissing book
tony stark was able to build this in a
cave
with a box of scraps
well i'm sorry i'm not tony stark